all right wordsmiths what's up the word
of the day today is regulate it means to
make rules that control something
I'll throw in a 10 second music break
tell me if you can identify any other
common English words that start with Reg
alright here we go music break
[Music]
all right so some related words are
regular regiment regime all of these
words are related to control or order
regulate comes from the Latin root reg
meaning straight like a ruler something
that's regular follows a rule or a
pattern it's predictable so something
that is regulated has been controlled by
a rule that's what that eight part means
it's a word part that makes verbs
because regulate is a verb it's an
action word so let's use regulate in
some sentences you can use it in a
literal sense like this valve regulates
how much fuel goes into the engine it is
literally controlling the rate of fuel
release but you can also use regulate to
refer to law making and I can use
another word part to make this verb into
a noun So Okay so we've got the word
regulate and let me Lop off the E on the
end
and add i o n and now it's a noun
regulation another word for a legal rule
state regulations only allow you to
catch three fish a week so here's two
Fisher folk dude
this woman has three fish so she's fine
this man has four fish so uh he's
probably gonna get a fine from Fish and
Wildlife because he didn't adhere to the
regulations sorry pal you've been
canceled by the government all right you
can learn anything
David out